this is probably the most irresponsible  thing I own we've all seen these silica  gel packets do not eat they contain  silica dioxide a material that absorbs  moisture really well to keep humidity  levels low but if ingested it can cause  internal blockages it can also irritate  your lungs and your eyes and your skin  basically do not eat it  but what if you want to  well my friend Dory who I've worked with  for years now runs a company called wasp  and they made these they look exactly  like do not eat silica gel packets but  inside well they're actually filled with  candy  mmm  now is this irresponsible to have around  is it a work of art is it a comment on  Humanity's fragility  and desires  yes